Погано видно. Треба було, щоб білий фон був.
Валентин працює охоронцем в Києві.
Під час карантину їздив на роботу з колегою на його машині.
Але цього разу зміни не співпали. Чоловік у відчаї.
Якщо викликати таксі, доведеться платити 500 гривень. Але в нього лише 50 гривень.
Це так пів дня добираюся. Добрих пів дня. Я по BlaBlaCar домовився.
Але він, можливо, нещодавно за кермом, побоявся в місто їхати. Сказав, я Київ не знаю.
З такими проблемами зіштовхуються майже щодня тисячі українців,
які вимушені шукати транспорт, аби доїхати на роботу або в інших нагальних справах
з одного населеного пункту в інший.
Відповідно до постанови уряду про карантин,
з 18-го березня в Україні були заборонені регулярні
і нерегулярні перевезення більше 10-ти людей.
Відтоді про поїздку з пункту А в пункт Б можна було домовитися
лише через сервіс BlaBlaCar або з перевізниками-нелегалами, які мають ось такі невеликі буси.
На них ні табличок з маршрутами, ні назви фірми.
Власники цих мікроавтобусів у розмові з DW розповіли,
що не вважають свою діяльність порушенням,
бо возять менше 10-ти людей,
допомагають людям у часи транспортного простою і заробляють гроші для своїх сімей.
Право на працю!
Це водії та власники мікроавтобусів та автобусів,
які здійснюють регулярні приміські та міжміські пасажирські перевезення.
Вони теж хочуть заробляти гроші для своїх родин, проте легально.
І вважають, що простоювати іплатити податки в той час,
коли нелегальні перевізники на цьому успішно заробляють, несправедливо.
Перевізники вважають, що відновлення автобусного сполучення на тлі послаблення карантину,
коли відкриваються торговельні заклади,
ресторани, кафе та зони відпочинку, теж абсолютно виправдано.
Два місяці сидимо вдома без роботи, дотримуємося законів.
Тобто нас закони стосуються, а нелегалів - ні. Вони спокійно їздять, їх ніхто не чіпає.
Я працюю на автовокзалі. І у мене нині немає можливості  працювати,
тому що не курсують автобуси, тому що заборонені перевезення більше 10 пасажирів.
Мені нічим годувати дитину.
У мене вже немає можливості платити за житло, я вже 2 місяці сиджу вдома.
Треба поступово якось рух відкривати. Хоча б дозволити автобуси на 10 пасажирів.
Чому в нас можуть ходити автобуси містом, але не можуть їздити за межі міста?
Я би запропонував відкрити регулярні перевезення, Можливо, не всі одразу.
Але на сьогодні село вкрай потребує перевезень.
Колгоспні ринки відкриті,
а селянин не може приїхати на ринок, продати те, що він виростив на городі.
Масові протести перевізників з вимогами відкрити пасажирські перевезення
прокотилися цІлою країною.
Перевізники вимагали від уряду пришвидшити цей процес.
На переговорах з урядом ухвалили попереднє рішення
відновити автобусні пасажирські перевезення з 22 травня.
Ми дійшли згоди, що є сенс відновити пасажирський рух одразу за всіма напрямками.
І 22 травня ми плануємо, якщо все буде добре, ми відриваємо
пасажирський рух. Це будуть і міські, і приміські, і міжобласні маршрути.
І міжнародні рейси в тому числі.
Працювати перевізники зможуть лише з дотриманням епідеміологічних правил.
Водію не слід отримувати за проїзд готівкою, квитки видають лише касири на автостанціях.
Керівництво автостанцій має забезпечити температурний скринінг пасажирів.
Водії повинні мати всі необхідні засоби захисту, передбачені санітарним законодавством.
Ми маємо можливість, за потреби, забезпечити антисептиками.
Це мінімальний комплект, що потрібен водію на сьогоднішній день:
захисні маски - декілька одиниць - та декілька комплектів гумових рукавичок з антисептиком.
Кількість пасажирів в автобусі, за попередньою домовленістю перевізників з урядом,
може дорівнювати кількості сидінь.
Якщо епідеміологічна ситуація знову погіршиться,
перевізники мають возити пасажирів, які сидітимуть у шаховому порядку в салоні -
тобто вдвічі менше, ніж сидячих місць.
Усі пасажири мають подорожувати в захисних масках.
Олексій Павленко з Асоціації перевізників Київщини
вважає, що таких заходів безпеки достатньо.
Стоячих пасажирів не повинно бути, навіть на приміському сполученні.
Я впевнений, що на початку роботи транспорту завантаження буде дуже низьке,
і не так швидко ми прийдемо до того моменту,
що треба буде чітко контролювати наповнення автобусів, щоб вписуватися в санітарні норми.
За підрахунками Олексія Павленка, через карантину на межі банкрутства
може опинитися кожен п'ятий приватний перевізник Київщини.
Приблизно такі ж дані і в асоціаціях перевізників в інших регіонах.
Перевізники заявляють про неефективність пільгових кредитних і зарплатних програм,
які були запропоновані урядом на підтримку підприємців, які постраждали під час епідемії.
В уряду дуже цікава програма щодо перевізників,
і вона називається "багато та ніколи".
Нічого ми не маємо, ніяких програм. Можливо, вони якісь адресні, для афілійованих компаній.
Те, що держава запропонувала компенсацію єдиного соціального внеску, - це смішно.
Смішно, коли перевізник, який досі більш-менш стояв на ногах, маючи 200-250 працівників,
на місяць мінімум півмільйона гривень податків має заплатити.
От хто заплатить йому ці податки сьогодні? Хто заплатить кредити?
Є багато перевізників, яким телефонують жінки водіїв і плачуть,
питають, коли чоловіки вийдуть на роботу.
До мене дзвонила дружина одного мого водія
і казала, що якщо щось є, дай, бо я буду продавати телевізор плазму свою...
Це ненормально. Люди вже не так бояться карантину, як бояться… вибачте, я скажу слово…
здохнути від голоду!
У міністерстві інфраструктури DW запевнили, що діалог з перевізниками буде продовжуватися.
Антикризовий план з урахуванням їхніх пропозицій
уже підготували для ухвалення урядом.
Це стосується підтримки бізнесу -
державної програми щодо зменшення податкового навантаження на
компанії-перевізники тощо.
Тобто суто економічно-фінансові інструменти.
Галузь пасажирських перевезень потребує більшої підтримки від держави,
вважає водій автобуса Олександр Тольченко.
Він бачить, як багато кваліфікованих робітників за два місяці втратили роботу.
Теперішні часи нагадують йому забуті 90-ті, коли на підприємствах не було ні грошей, ні роботи.
Люди, які працювали в інших організаціях, приходять просять
навіть слюсарем, щоб крутити якусь гайку, щоб якусь копійку заробити…
За 100-200 гривень приходять, аби додому шматок хліба купити.
Олександр з колегою не виключають, що і їм, можливо, доведеться шукати іншу роботу.
Його підприємство 22 травня, скоріше за все, не вийде на маршрути,
бо автобуси курсують між аеропортом та залізничним вокзалом.
Регулярне авіасполучення поки не відкрито.
А залізниця може розпочати повноцінну роботу лише в червні.
І то лише у разі, якщо після відкриття приміських та міжміських перевезень
не буде різкого зростання кількості хворих на коронавірус.
У перемовинах з перевізниками уряд наголосив,
що в такому випадку можуть знову запровадити обмеження на перевезення.
Щоправда, влада пішла на поступки, визнавши, що заборонятимуть не по всій країні одразу.
Якщо певний регіон має якесь погіршення ситуації, то, власне,
щодо цього регіону буде застосовуватися інший підхід
будуть, знову ж таки, вимушено застосовуватися обмежувальні заходи.
Мешканець Фастова Валентин після майже двогодинного очікування на трасі
нарешті спіймав автомобіль, який довезе його додому.
Наступна його робоча зміна в Києві через тиждень,
і він сподівається їхати на роботу вже рейсовим автобусом.
Він, як і інші опитані DW перевізники,
вважає, що повністю припиняти роботу транспорту -
навіть у разі погіршення епідеміологічної ситуації - більше не можна.